let's bring in Adam Sandler who if you
are watching you can see some of the
movie posters that I have some of the
legendary movies their films I think
they're not movies art house theater
that Sandler movie posters that are up
there there is one movie poster that
Sandler sent to me and he autographed it
to somebody named Janet so like I don't
know what happened but I got it and I go
Sam man sent me a movie poster and he
autographed it and it says you know dear
Janet and I went okay well that's close
Sandman joins us now good morning
Sandman Danny Danny
that what happened was the studio's give
me one poster each movie yeah
Janet it was a dear dear friend and and
I was making it out too and then I get a
text Janet said I'm not feeling well and
I didn't really enjoy that movie and so
I said okay well I won't send you the
poster please that's very nice thank you
I don't believe you for one second I'm
very happy for you guys getting the new
move getting a new life a new start on
things and how big is that place is it
bigger oh my gosh it's crazy it's a
field house I did this happen how did
this happen I don't know I think that I
took management now it got him liquored
up and then I said you know I'm thinking
of a new man cave
and then they're like oh okay and I
found a place it's like you you got
Netflix liquored up and then you said
I'm thinking about making some movies
here
that's probably what have to leave it
now carefully I'm very happy for well
deserved you bring so much happiness to
everybody
last night I was at my kids play and
this man walked up to me and says were
you do me a favor and he grabbed both my
hands and stared me in the eyes I said
yes would you say hi to Dan Patrick for
me and so hello to you buddy was that
David Spade who did that it was a lawn
Michael oh by the way no you're you're
hosting Saturday Night Live for the very
first time on May
for that's that's like big-boy stuff
there how'd this come about
yeah why not Danny I'll go knock it out
for you buddy but are you gonna come by
it's on a Saturday man well coming hang
can I can I come in for the rehearsal
yeah yeah yeah you can't stay up that
late no but what about going to the
after-party after the boys want to come
okay
now you can't put this out there like
you it can't be a fake invite they're
right here Sam and you're gonna crush
their heart okay now I'm gonna give you
a chance
okay the after party they're not coming
to the show I don't want to look out and
see them at all I just want to see them
at the party staring at all the famous
people all right
Seaton you have a statement for the
dance well yeah I mean don't tease us
this is an amazing opportunity is it a
fake invite Sandman yeah it's a real
invite oh it is like the coral party yes
and I'm sure all those guys would like
to talk sports with you too
who is the music guest Shawn Mendes try
to keep hands off oh yeah
he's hottie you know what Amy yes yeah
yeah you say hitmaker are you gonna
perform with him I don't know I'm going
there as a jest of the show's a and
those guys are gonna write write up a
stuff and I can't wait any fun
Sandman's always kicking also kicking up
his 100% fresher tour may 31st if you
didn't see it on Netflix his stand-up
was awesome it was really really well
done a lot of guitar you finally brought
the guitar out I kept saying Sandman
you're a whole lot funnier when you
bring the guitar out it's a crutch when
I background I see any tension I just go
[Laughter]
so much up here what is your favorite
moment from Saturday Night Live when you
are a performer
well probably the biggest moment what I
sang red hooded sweatshirt and Paul and
Linda McCartney sang with me and that
was the thing I probably talked about
most of my life would he was and I sat
in a room and met Paul and Linda and
children what a what I was asking him to
be a part of and there was a very silly
and but they were just so calm when
there was so nice to me man they were
nice to me the rest of the week and I
get to hang out with them and their
family after at the after show I don't
know where they fail it was incredible
so you know the be the Beatles in my
house and everybody's house meant so
much that you know telling my sisters
and my brother and my parents that I was
with Paul that was the best that was the
best I never got the true story on when
you did your audition because I heard
there were a couple of different
versions of when you auditioned
can you clear up what you did in your
did you take off clothes in your
audition
no no no I did I just did stand-up I was
out there in Chicago I went on up like
maybe ten guys six guys audition for lon
and I think marci klein and Roberts
Michael saw us go up and me and rock and
a few other great guys and and somehow I
was on the plane ride home and they just
had those those phones that you you know
you you it cost like fifteen minutes and
you're called and I was oh man I don't
know if I can I can do that quite yet
this 15 hours a minute thing I could
definitely see my fault beating me
senseless pursuing it but I dialed a
thing that got the agent I said yeah
yeah they called I missed your callers
on the plane going I say they caught
something so now you hadn't met your
wife
prior to Saturday Night Live right okay
no well maybe when we were kids you know
down in Florida I bumped into her and I
and we were unaware but but I don't know
were you a big stars
you know like in New York were you a big
star were you hanging out with famous
people back then I was always kind of
goofy always kind of I ran around but
you know we ran around with our crew our
cast and in numbers felt cool when we
were together we felt like we were rock
band but alone I still felt like myself
a little a little nervous
he's Adam Sandler he's got his 100%
fresher tour you're also going to be
close to us June 25th Sandman you're
gonna be in Bridgeport Connecticut now
I'm about 15 minutes away yeah you gotta
come and bring bring everybody no no I
wanted you to come to my man cave oh my
god yo you want me to come over yeah
yeah yeah sure well maybe you guys have
come to the show too
all right I'll do that thankfully come
to the man cave yeah either the day of
or the the next day in the morning
depending on what time I get oh I get
this basketball court is unbelievable I
mean I basically build it for you
geez yeah thank you I know you did and
that but but I am so happy for it
everybody
they district own bananas show that
that's why they they did this big
opening thing that's to gets huge boys
I'm happy and then we'll check in with
you that May 4th Saturday Night Live
where Sandman is going to be hosting
with Shawn Mendes and then the dentist's
get to go to the what happens at the
after-party just so I know like is it
it's not it's not Belushi like I think
it's not crazy I mean I think I think
you know it's yes I'm sure it's it's
civil I'm sure there's a you you don't
crank you don't drink you enjoy it buddy
you guys think it's imposing and some
eating and socialize events about it but
it goes late and everyone's tired the
next day and
I gotta tell ya that's the only part a
little become tense about being able to
stay awake with everybody is it open bar
that's what the dance want to know okay
all right
you asked that if I drank remember when
we were in Hawaii would just go with it
and the first time I ever met Dave
Matthews you put me across the table
from him and he go Danny a Dave Matthews
you got a lot in common you like to
drink I went to shake his hand I knocked
my beer over all over his lap but I tell
you what Danny ain't nobody nobody wake
up as early as you can a sailor has a
rule on the movie said don't get in the
headlines don't be in the newspaper
don't do anything like that so I I'm
trying to play nice
everybody's got their families out there
my family's not there and nick swardson
great comedian wants to go out and yeah
that didn't go well for Swardson
cuz he went out hard he started out fast
but wouldn't last and I get to the set
the next day and we can't find Nick
Swardson can't find him and Sandler goes
Danny what happened with smarty I said
Sam and I have no idea oh I know is the
next day sentence shortened finally came
in he had sand all over him he had slept
in a sand trap at the golf course across
from the hotel and also the other thing
that I told the this story the other day
when we were on stage the first time
with the hula dancing when Nicole Kidman
came out in her outfit and had a
six-pack and I'm talking about her
stomach she had just had a baby and
looked unbelievable
now Aniston is standing next to me
Sandman and she sees Kidman look like
that dance
that an Aniston says you got to be bleep
and kidding me and and that's when she
called you out she goes Adam Adam c'mere
and that's when you said no play it big
play it for laughs
which she did because I don't think she
realized that Nicole Kidman was going to
look like that and dance like that well
I'll tell ya old Aniston you know I did
a movie with Aniston again and it's kind
and it's coming out and she looks
unbelievable I gotta say and Aniston our
bodies it's saying I don't know what the
hell these how they do it because Aston
can sit with a half-shirt and if i sat
with a half-shirt it's horrible standing
on because it's being covered but yeah I
think that's again on the greatness and
those are in the colas unbelievable yeah
you did couldn't that say Danny
you always get beautiful women in your
movies I mean god bless you but you look
back Emanuel shrieky in Zohan
like come on yet awesome yes yes
absolutely absolutely but but but
honestly look look at me look at the you
know at certain angles how great I look
at other scoliosis angles not as well
but you catch me at the right angle I
like I get along with the beauty yeah
you do yeah occasionally you look hot
hopefully you'll do well in Saturday
Night Live Sandman thank you
congratulations on the 100% fresh or
tour that's May 31st and of course
Saturday Night Live we Shawn Mendes that
will be May 4th we'll be in touch
sentiment right thank you buddy Happy
Passover now and a Happy Easter at all I
love you guys and and that
congratulations really happy for you man
and I miss you
Thank You Sandman that's an Adam Sandler
and I do believe he means that there you
go I don't know if you're invited into
the Saturday Night Live performance but
if you guys want to go after party we're
good to go
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on Br
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app